Welcome back everyone this will be my new
marvel eternals video all about galactus and
the celestials the writers of the eternals movie
we're talking about using him in the next film so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we have marvel disney plus day happening real soon
with a bunch of trailers i'll be doing videos for
all those careful for spoilers for the eternals
movie if you haven't seen it yet because i'll be
talking about some of the big plot points in the
history of the mcu the history of the celestials
and what galactus has to do with that but since
the movie has come out the writers of the movie
have been talking about bringing galactus into
the mcu and doing him in eternals 2 the sequel
movie and how he sort of figures into their cosmic
mcu plans for where they're taking things during
marvel phase 4 in marvel phase 5 on a larger
avengers level scale there were a lot of theories
that they would use galactus as a sort of avengers
5 or avengers 6 kind of villain because he is that
big and we're doing a new fantastic four franchise
so everybody's kind of been thinking about him in
the background but this is what the marvel writers
said they said galactus is an amazing character
and villain we are obviously setting the stage
for intergalactic cosmic megalith confrontations
especially when you kill a space god talking
about the plot of the eternal movie and then
kind of killing tiamut effectively he's dead they
turned him to stone so he's supposed to be dead
and then the space god comes and kidnaps you and
plans to judge earth i think the door is very
much open for world eating villains technically
galactus doesn't eat worlds he eats the cosmic
energy inside worlds but they call him the hunger
so it feels kind of like he's eating a planet then
they go on to say there's definitely conversations
about these post-credit sequences about what
they're introducing where we're going galactus is
one of those iconic figures of the marvel universe
that we're excited to see but sometimes i think
you leave yourself open you leave the doors open
and who knows what's happening in number two
maybe you're too busy saving a celestial from
galactus that you end up incurring his wrath
anything is possible that should answer all your
questions about why galactus didn't show up in
a post-credits scene it sounds like they thought
about it but it was just a little too soon to
actually bring him into the mcu because we haven't
seen silver surfer yet and they haven't done
the new fantastic four movie yet but clearly the
eternals writers have had a lot of conversations
with marvel behind the scenes about how they use
galactus in the next movie the plot that he
explains there might change a little but he's
suggesting the galactus would actually be fighting
the celestials just because of this big megalith
cosmic confrontations they're talking about there
aren't that many characters that are physically as
large as galactus and the celestials but they're
about the same size like galactus about the same
size as arishem the judge sort of like godzilla
versus kong but make it marvel and make it outer
space the arrogance of man is thinking nature
is in our control and not the other way around
let them fight that would be a little
bit different from his relationship to
the celestials in the comics in the
comics galactus actually views them
as being the bigger fish if you're talking
about apex predators in fact the eternal story
that they adapted for the movie neil gaiman's
eternals run with tiamut the dreaming celestial
waking up and the eternals trying to stop that
from happening on earth galactus was actually
featured in that story and starts to get afraid
when it senses that a new celestial is being born
but based on what the eternals writers said it
sounds like in the mcu they're going to be using
galactus in a slightly different way making him
more powerful than the celestials or at least as
powerful even in the comics the reason why he's
so powerful is because galactus is technically the
combination of two different characters so he's
a combination of the scientist galen from the
previous version of the universe he survived the
big bang because he merged with the sixth version
of eternity before it died and became the seventh
version like the current version of eternity
if you're not familiar with the concept of
eternity i've mentioned him in previous eternals
videos they talk about him during guardians of
the galaxy 2 they mentioned the concept eternity
several times during the eternals movie but never
talk about it as if it's an actual character yet
there's a lot of lies that they learn about
during the eternals movie about their origins
and the celestials what they're really doing
in the universe so this whole idea that the
celestials just didn't burst out of nothingness
something actually created it and that something
was eternity it's meant to be the living
embodiment of the universe and the multiverse
at the beginning of the movie sersi gives this
big lecture to her students at the natural history
museum about apex predators and the way they use
it in this scene here is meant to be a reference
to the eternal's relationship with humans and
the deviants like they're the apex predators on
earth but secretly it's also a sly reference to
the celestials in the way the eternals view them
so take that a step further next big twist there
are bigger fish out there bigger apex predators
beyond the celestials in the marvel universe there
are also a lot of power-ups that lesser characters
like the eternals can gain like the unimine that
helped them kill celestials making them kind of
like the apex predators so there's always a bigger
fish out there galactus being one of them the plot
that the eternals writers teased here the eternals
themselves saving a celestial from galactus they
didn't say if it's a fully grown celestial or
if it's saving celestial seeds in planets from
galactus but his whole thing is consuming planets
rich in cosmic energy he doesn't actually eat the
plants themselves like i said he just sucks
the cosmic energy out of them in planets with
celestial seeds in the mcu would be super rich in
that kind of energy like a tasty galactus snack
and since the eternals movie just sets up so
much cosmic history of the mcu it makes sense
that they'd also use galactus in some way or
incorporate him into the celestial's overarching
story going forward but it's kind of like the
backstory for ego the living planet so in the
comics ego the living planet is not a celestial
but they made him a celestial inside the mcu
i'm what's called a celestial sweetheart so
we'll see if marvel decides to change that
for galactus backstory but he is a little
bit different galactus is called the hunger
because he goes around eating cosmic energy
and planets so it sounds like he's doing the
opposite of what the celestials is doing but they
actually kind of serve the same cosmic purpose
during the movie arishem tells sersi that the
reason the celestials exist their sole mission
is to create new suns so that new galaxies can
form and new life can grow helping the universe
to continue existing if they stopped doing that if
all the celestials died the universe would enter
heat death much faster than intended and you can't
fight entropy so at the end of the day at some
point we know from the loki series he who remains
version of kang that the main mcu universe that
we're in the sacred timeline has to end eventually
so at some point the celestials will die one way
or another it's just a question of how many more
billions of years we have during the opening crawl
of the movie also the first opening crawl that
marvel's ever done they imply that arishem the
judge was created before the six singularities
that formed into the infinity stones pre-dating
the big bang so unless arishem is lying that
means that he predates the universe he existed
in the void of nothingness chaos where the dark
elves came from galactus is also a character who
technically predates the mcu universe as we know
it now because he comes from the previous version
of the universe and was sort of the he who remains
of that universe there's this concept of the cycle
of big bang's the cycle of cosmic renewal
where the big bang happens universe slowly
forms obviously we have a marvel multiverse now
so this is happening in many different universes
but as the universe forms billions of years later
it eventually goes into heat death contracts into
itself and eventually goes through another big
bang cycle and a new universe is born becoming
a totally different version than the one before
galactus was a normal scientist named galen in the
last living society alive in his version of the
universe right before the heat death in next big
bang as his version of the multiverse started to
collapse in on itself and go into another big bang
cycle he basically flew his spaceship directly
into the singularity as it was forming it was
able to survive the big bang because the version
of eternity from his multiverse merged its dying
essence with him and they became the combined
galactus being so that's why galactus became so
powerful because he basically has all the power of
a version of eternity but even though most stories
use galactus as the antagonist he's technically
not a villain it's the same thing with the
celestials the celestials aren't meant to be good
or evil they just serve this grand cosmic purpose
the funny thing about galactus ii to sort of bring
this back around to thanos and his plan to balance
the universe is that's also kind of what galactus
does when he consumes planets the scale is again
in balance all is as it was perfectly balanced
this whole thing should be he's kind of like a
cosmic farmer doing controlled burns on fields
helping enrich the soil to make new crops grow
stronger faster people do the same thing in
real life with big patches of dead trees to help
larger forests continue living in bringing this
back around to the new fantastic four movies that
marvel is setting up right now galactus sort of
goes hand in hand with the silver surfer character
usually you see him first and he is the herald of
galactus so then you know the galactus is coming
when he shows up there's a lot of theories that
the new mystery character that james gunn just
cast in guardians of the galaxy 3 is the new
mcu silver surfer so chuckwudi iwuji is someone
who he just finished working with on the suicide
squad movie the peacemaker series he posted this
photo of them starting to film guardians 3 but
didn't say who he was playing just said that he
given him the guardians 3 part that everyone
in hollywood wanted and after adam warlock
who is the character that every single person
in hollywood would want to play in that movie
silver surfer just a really solid theory also
because of where they're taking that character
in future movies he's just a really huge deal in
the mcu the actor chikudi iwuji has also won this
laundry list of acting awards for shakespeare
plays that he's done and silver surfer has this
very shakespearean way about him his personality
you may remember lawrence fishburne's performance
as silver surfer in the original fantastic four
movies he was just the voice of the character doug
jones did the physical camera performance it is
known by many names my people called it galactus
the devourer of worlds if you don't know what's
going on with the new fantastic four reboot movie
that marvel's doing they're actually doing it with
john watts the director of spider-man no way home
in all the mcu spider-man movies a lot of you've
also theorized that galactus would become a future
avengers villain like avengers 5 marvel phase 5
avengers 6 beyond why would galactus come to earth
well now we have a dead celestial full of cosmic
energy just sitting inside what seems like the
indian ocean think of galactus as sort of like the
cosmic janitor let me come clean that up for you
my early theory right now for the first time we
actually see galactus for real in the mcu or the
first time they actually tease him would be one of
the new fantastic four movies post-credits scenes
like the new fantastic four movie introduces the
new team what their big mission is going to be
they use one of the post-credits scenes as a sort
of avengers 5 avengers 6 lead in for larger cosmic
avengers level threats like galactus but everyone
let me know in the comments if the eternals
writers are talking about using galactus in the
sequel movies what do you actually want them to
do with the character really big reminder marvel
disney plus day trailers are coming on friday
there'll be a bunch of marvel trailers there's
rumors that they're also going to drop the star
wars obi-wan kenobi trailer maybe a moon night
trailer she-hulk trailer and hopefully some
announcements about upcoming new marvel series
that they haven't talked about yet i'm really
crossing my fingers for a kit harrington
black knight series that would be amazing
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel to be the first to watch those
and everyone click here for my spider-man no
way home toby mcguire and andrew garfield video
and click here for my full
eternals post credit scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!